the foreign secretary has launched a new
fund to help prevent sexual violence in
Conflict James cleverly made the
announcement at a global Summit in
London and earlier Ukraine's first lady
Elena zelenska spoke at the conference
and accused Rush of using sexual
violence as a weapon of War Skies Ashna
hoynak spoke to her and heard from some
women who've been victims and her report
does contain some graphic descriptions
of sexual violence
2014 Irina and Elisa were sexually
assaulted at the hands of Russian
soldiers in Ukraine
at a global Summit on preventing sexual
violence in Conflict they shared their
stories with the world for the first
time
they held me in captivity for five days
and those were horrible five days I was
interrogated by the local collaborators
I was beaten humiliated and had to
undergo continuous tortures
at one point I realized that I just
stopped being a person they were not
treating me as a human
Elisa had been filming a documentary
when she was captured in the donesque
region she was sexually abused by a
Russian commander and he forced me to
take out of my closes and take a bath in
front of him
and after he didn't let me put any
clothes in me only like a small towel
and he put his gun in front of me and he
was cleaning his gun and he was just
enjoying his power that he can can do
whatever he wants and I could do nothing
almost naked next to him and after he
tried to rape me nine years later and
their country's first lady is in London
to remind people history is repeating
itself this is another weapon in their
Arsenal in this world conflict that's
why they're using this systematically
and openly they're very open about this
that is why it's extremely important to
recognize nice this as a war crime our
own teams in Ukraine have seen evidence
of this we filmed at this house in a
village outside Keith where two Russian
soldiers allegedly raped two Ukrainian
women one of them was vika who told us
why she wanted to share her ordeal
history
that the aim for people here sexual
violence condemns survivors to a
lifetime of trauma this platform is
about them sharing their voice
in central London